what's popping Monster Hunters it's me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show y'all and holy moly was that such
an emotional and badass finale for
Monarch Legacy of Monsters season 1
hopefully there's going to be a season 2
if there's not going to be one I'm going
to send letters lots and lots of letters
but like always spoilers ahead because
we have got to talk about this ending
and what it could mean for the future of
legendaries monsterverse so let's get it
on like King Kong and break this mother
dang finale down shall we but yo before
I do give this video a like yeah it
takes 2 seconds it would make everybody
on team heavy spoilers Happy on the
inside and you want to do that right you
want to make us happy you like to spread
Christmas cheer even though it's not
Christmas anymore spread some January
cheer why don't you all right so first
of all I would like to start this
breakdown by telling you all that I told
you so like I've been saying in my
breakdown videos of Monarch this entire
season and a little bit in my follow-up
videos for Loki season 2 gravity be
doing some weird ass [__] to SpaceTime
and science man because gravity and time
are inextricably Linked In The Cosmos
and no one in this episode knows this
better than poor K Randa played
masterfully this entire season by
actress Mari Yamamoto because my god did
this world's wonky ass gravity caused
this science lady to miss out on a lot
of important birthdays and the scene
that we got this episode when KO learns
about how much she's lost in the 57 days
that she's been trapped in her
mysterious Forest time PR
was probably my favorite scene of this
entire season because of how emotional
Koo and Lee's reunion was like watching
KO suffer a near mental breakdown while
trying to accept the loss of her entire
reality was incredibly heartbreaking
like Mari Yamamoto works so damn well
with both Kurt and Wyatt Russell because
their chemistry tends to produce a lot
of emotionally resonating scenes like
these are all fantastic actors because
while it was 57 days of being Kaiju
Katniss everines in the woods of of a
parallel reality for Koo a full 56 years
have actually passed by in the human
people world where people are paying
bills and being depressed and
unfortunately for KO she would learn
that during those years that she was
missing her husband Bill Randa would
obsessively spend the rest of his life
trying to avenge the death of his wife
leaving his son Hiroshi with first a
distracted father then eventually
followed by a deceased father when Bill
randa's Kaiju Obsession would of course
lead him to become a skullcrawler Happy
Meal in 1973
during the events of Kong Skull Island
but anyways during her two-month stay in
this new realm KO decided to give her
new home a name specifically access
Mundy as access Mundy is the Latin term
for the conceptual Center axis of the
world from which the world spins with
that axis usually depicted in the form
of either a giant world- siiz tree or a
mountain cutting through the very center
of a spherical Globe to reach up to the
heavens and because the axis Mundy acts
as a pillar between the Earth and the
heavens itself KO had decided to make
this bridge World between the hellish
Hollow Earth Below and the peaceful
human world above after that bridging
concept as well but anyways now that we
know exactly where this new plane of
existence is in relation to the upper
and Hollow Earth realities of the
monsterverse we might also begin to
understand the potential significance of
this blue and orange glow of this new
realm that I went into briefly in my
last Monarch video in that video I
hypothesized that the blue and orangish
yellow of the axis Mundy world could
potentially represent both the blue
energies that live inside the hollow
Earth and Godzilla and the orange
energies that are closely associated
with Kong and his species however now
that we know that the axis Mundy is a
bridge World between the hollow Earth
and regular Earth those blue and orange
energy signatures might just represent
the colors of both these two world's
main power sources the mysterious blue
power of the hollow Earth and the orange
yellow power of the human realm's Sun
through Apex cybernetics is trip to the
hollow Earth in Godzilla versus Kong we
learn that the very ground of the hollow
Earth itself and all of the Kaiju that
eat the food from that ground are all
powered by this mysterious blue power
source with Godzilla being the most
powerful example of such an irradiated
Kaiju Powerhouse Kong is more affiliated
with the orange energy of this universe
because Kong and his ancestors were
mysteriously banished from the hollow
Earth to live under the orange glow of
Humanity's yellow sun on Skull Island so
having the background of axis Mundy be
blue and orange seems to symbolize the
two Realms that the axis mondy Dimension
resides between because we learned in
this episode that the axis Mundy is
entirely comprised of elements from the
hollow Earth as well as the human Earth
so such a symbolically colored
background would be fitting here and I
also thought it was an extra nice touch
to see the cinematography of this
episode continue to use this blue and
orange in the background when canaro is
thinking about his interdimensionally
trapped friend May at the bar that they
went to when they first met but anyways
after Koo meets up with everyone she
reveals that she was the one who has
been sending the distress signals that
Monarch has been picking up from all the
Rifts acting up in the world
specifically by reconfiguring Dr
Suzuki's gamma ray emitter to send out a
distinctive SOS to anyone in the above
human world who might be listening and
if it wasn't for Monarch agent Barn's
ability to see koo's mysterious pattern
and Tim's insistence on following that
pattern the gang would not have been
able to be rescued by a Apex cybernetics
at the very end of the episode as Tim
would convince both canaro and Hiroshi
Randa to make a deal with the cybernetic
Devils at Apex in order to locate the
source of that signal and hopefully find
Kate and may along the way but
unfortunately when Lee and KO hook up
koo's gamma machine to Lee's underspace
exploratory pod from his 1962 journey to
this strange new place they are greeted
with their second reunion of the day in
the form of the giant ion Dragon Kaiju
that they ran into in the Philippines in
1952 potentially the very same Kaiju
that was also responsible for the deaths
of some of Le's Monarch crew mates but
if it's not the same Kaiju then it's for
sure the same ion Dragon species but the
most hype moment of the episode of
course comes when Godzilla comes out of
nowhere with the mother freaking steel
chair to save the goddamn day that was
legit the coolest freaking thing ever
and getting to see Godzilla continue to
kick absolute ass like he gets paid for
it with such a satisfying way to end
this season like Godzilla absolutely
annihilated that stupid bird but I did
notice that during the fight the ion
Dragon shot out a ton of gross Dragon
saliva in Godzilla's face which was
super rude but also made me think back
to how the USS ltin was covered in the
ion dragon's gross saliva when Bill and
KO first got there at the beginning of
the season so it seems like the ion
Dragon species are quite liberal with
where they spread their saliva just like
my ex-wife I'm kidding I've never been
married I own too many comic books but
while this fight was dope what was
significantly less dope was having to
see leaw sacrifice himself to protect
the woman that he has always loved I
mean yeah while I very much saw
something like this coming as actor Kurt
Russell is not exactly the most
inexpensive and readily available actor
in Hollywood it was incredibly sad to
see leaw go out like that man but while
this moment was a major bummer at the
same time I was like hold on on a minute
am I actually sad to see a human being
in legendaries monsterverse die that
kind of rules man because let's be real
here up until this point legendaries
monsterverse has struggled to get people
to care about the human characters of
their films because when people go to
see a Godzilla or Kong movie in theaters
they are more so expecting to see kaijus
killing more so than people chilling you
know what I'm saying you only spend so
much time with the human characters in
the movies that when they die it doesn't
really feel like that big of a a deal
however after spending 10 whole episodes
becoming invested in the shaw Randa
narrative I've become significantly more
emotionally invested in what happens to
these TV show characters than I am with
Millie Bobby Brown and tapwater guy but
I'm speaking more so on the American
side because Godzilla minus one has
definitely got that covered so I am
definitely hoping legendary gives this
show a season two to continue to grow
the monsterverse in that way because
actually getting to see the human and
societal Fallout of the arrival of these
Godlike Monsters has done wonders for
making this feel like a living Cinematic
Universe filled with personality history
and science but anyways like I mentioned
before after Lee Shaw's heroic sacrifice
to get Koo Kate and may back to their
home Dimension the ladies are greeted by
Apex cybernetics corporate goon squad
Army along with koo's son and Grandson
but soon after that tearful reunion KO
Kate and may are not only hit with the
surprise that they have a giant ass
temperamental gorilla as their new
neighbor on apex's research station on
Skull Island but that the weird ass
gravity of the axis Mundi has caused two
years to pass in the human world while
they were down there making it now the
year 2017 in that time it seems that
canaro has begun to follow in his father
and grandfather's footsteps by becoming
heavily involved with the work Apex has
been doing to supposedly help fighting
these monsters supposedly cuz we know
that those [__] cannot be
trusted but I thought this ending for
canaro was super fitting considering
Cano's painting that we saw earlier in
the season in May's apartment it was a
picture of a lone sci-fi Warrior facing
off against a giant Kaiju very much a
piece of foreshadowing for kentaro's own
future as a random Monster Hunter and I
also thought it was super fitting to see
the show ending the way that it started
with the Randa once again on Skull
Island as the series of course started
with a quick Cameo from John Goodman's
Bill Randa recording a message for his
estranged son Hiroshi but anyway since
it is now 2017 by the end of the season
this means that the show has ended a
full two years before the events of
2019s Godzilla king of the monsters and
seven years before Walter Simmons
reveals Apex cybernetics true intentions
with meca Godzilla in Godzilla versus
Kong so seeing Kong on Skull Island
definitely makes sense here as he was
for sure still chilling on that island
before he got relocated to the hollow
Earth in the year 2024 and we also know
that by 2019 Monarch had already had
King Kong under surveillance at Monarch
Skull Island Outpost 236 so this being
the case something must have happened
between 2017 and 2019 to warant a
research team change from Apex
cybernetics to Monarch on Skull Island
events that a season 2 of Monarch Legacy
of monsters could potentially cover if a
season 2 were to happen and it should
and it should I could definitely see
that season being centered around Skull
Island and discovering the very place
that was the focus of Grandpa randa's
Obsession like I know for damn sure that
KO is going to want to try to finish the
research that her husband Bill started
on the island herself especially with
all that time surviving in the axis
Mundy by herself surviving on Skull
Island should definitely be a lot easier
for KO than for most other people and we
all know that koo's Curiosity knows no
bounds Skull Island for sure seems like
the perfect setting for a second season
of Monarch in my opinion because there
is still so much that we don't know
about that place to this day but anyways
that is it for these breakdowns of
Monarch Legacy of monsters thank you
guys so much for joining me during this
journey you guys have been amazing you
can follow me at mastertainment on
Twitter or Instagram or YouTube or
wherever I am on the internet but most
importantly please follow heavy spoilers
here on YouTube and when you do make
sure you hit that notification Bell so
that you can get notifications every
time we upload a video but yes thank you
guys again for watching you guys are
amazing and I love you guys so much and
I'll see you guys some other time stay
safe and you know try not to fall into
any you know portals to the hollow Earth
or you know any other adjacent realities
by the time I see you next at your
homework catch you guys later bye